yeah welcome to new video it's a
five-minute game and um he's playing the
Benoni ok I'll see if he also knows the
Sicilian transporting it 2morrow gambit
uh huh quickly playing a six maybe p5
also now if you place be five well then
the usual Bishop c4 is not possible
anymore maybe we should be 395 something
like this 95 immediately you play 60 k
there should be three my play is sex
outside hmm
yeah quick we should have formed I don't
know it looks like something that should
be refuted in a way I don't see how I
could I could on before i could play
Bishop c4 takes on c3 and 25 threatening
made on f7 and threatening the rook ok
so we prevented this yes lil night is
hanging I'm not sure I want to move it
to you too I could play 9595 Bishop d7
if he takes I can take with the Queen
yeah he just moves instantly but now i
can cancel if he takes a check with the
porn and then follow up with g6 and
rookie one this is some interesting i
just lost a bit of time
to get to this position but that may be
quite quite okay uh-huh so if i go
Bishop f4 now he takes I take with the
Queen how does he protect f7 I guess he
doesn't okay he takes with the porn i
can also take with the pawn it said it's
interesting tried to play d 6 he has 95
okay but also queen d 5 is not bad at
all so ok let's take now and he would
need to take with the king I'm to him
not get hurt Lucy porn immediately so
what now he may is he trying to play the
e5 maybe let's go here go threatening
boo boo 6 or similar stuff ok just I'm
developed yam how to continue it's
obviously fine position in but I need to
to open it up of course Queenie to and
then we five maybe yeah maybe I should
have done Queenie to rookie one don't
know
yeah now threatening e5 this would have
been better better before okay so now
will I take it and now it's in a
boatload of Pencey m95 coming yeah well
it's not especially fun to play this
position as black it's probably just
losing so should I just pile up on c6 I
don't see what is what is doing to to
prevent to prevent this really it's 94
an idea okay let's let's take this away
he cannot move from anything anyway yeah
crap like this is possible i'm running
so just drop d to add roxy tune and c6
is gone if i take it might take and play
neither you 94 yeah now I'm just
threatening all those discoveries just
95 or whatever everything winds
basically I guess I can also just take
it in come on let's just take the pawn
is still as no no way to to get out of
this I'm threatening all kinds of stuff
95-year 95 and now
seven is gone cha cha yeah woke up ja
only down to 20 seconds but it's fairly
simple okay yeah well I think I'll
manage black resigns yeah this was
pretty neat cannot take here let's check
this quickly i'm not sure about this a 4
but it was interesting and while it
cannot take so 6 is fine certainly no 95
yeah we still cannot really take
and here yeah computer actually once p
should be three but this shouldn't be
bad really now this gives me goose this
is a quad huge advantage e takes d5
queen txt five and he cannot protect f7
yeah and now it's just it's just our
probably I can I can execute this better
in a way like rookie one was good fruit
be one certainly wasn't the best maybe
Queenie to rookie won something like
this look so looks looks terrible d 6
yeah meet them yeah thanks for watching